sometimes you have to disappoint people
in order to do the thing you want to do
which I feel like I've done throughout
my career pretty well
like a serial disappoint there it's like
what else
the sooner I realize that not everyone's
gonna like you
the more free my comedy became I feel
like the culmination of your freedom was
the White House Correspondents Dinner in
2018 where like I thought that was the
most courageous set might have ever seen
you know like you can almost see like
the the resistance going up and you were
just like plowing through it like a
fireball it was so awesome I think so
what was your reaction to the firestorm
after the Correspondents Dinner that you
probably knew was coming I knew it what
I was doing I just didn't know it would
blow up as big as it did I had similar
experiences I my manager took all the
headlines and he framed all the good
ones and then next to it he framed all
the bad ones I mean of course people
were gonna say negative things but I was
pretty shocked that they thought I made
fun of Sara's looks because literally
two days before the dinner I had some
looks based jokes in there for Kellyanne
and I took them out because one of my
friends who read it was like I think you
should take out the jokes about looks
because I I have a feeling that's what
the media will make it about and I was
like you know that's a good call I was
sad because I really loved the joke but
it was a good call and I was like you're
right let's do that I took out the joke
and then I was like wait but I you're
still gonna get mad at looks I should
have told the joke I really wanted to
tell ya but that's when I was like oh
the media is even more like complicit
than I thought they were you know like
oh you guys either are willfully
ignorant or you're trying to maintain
some sort of access that you have and I
tend to believe it was the latter
because I don't think any of them are
stupid enough to actually think that
that was a look space
[Music]